hello everybody my name is markiplier
and no the title is not a lie it's not
clickbait here is my number right now it
is five one three two eight six two one
seven two and you can text that number
right now and you'll get a response from
me I've been working with this company
called digits who've helped set all this
up and have been really nice and very
smart in getting the system all together
but it really works you'll get a
response back with a link that lets you
fill out some contact info so I can add
you to my phonebook from there we need
things like zip code birthday name and
email but with that information like the
zip code if I'm going back to Cincinnati
to visit my family and I want to do a
meet and greet while I'm there instead
of tweeting out to the whole world I can
just text people in Cincinnati directly
if I'm here in LA and I need extras to
help out in a video that I'm filming
which I do because we're filming a big
Worf stash thing that I'll talk about
later but if I needed extras and I do I
can text people in the LA area to see if
they're free to come and be in a video
for van videos if I do more of those I
can have people join me wherever I go
across the country with that van now
this only works in the US for now they
will roll out international soon it's
just that messaging works differently
across the entire world but it's not
just for information this allows me to
actually talk with you guys it's not a
robot
there's no AI that's trying to pretend
to be me I can sort down and see every
single conversation that I have with
every single one of you the reason we
collect information is so that we can
just sort through everything because
there are many many people that are
going to Texas number but I can see
everything you send me if you send me
memes I can respond with another meme if
you send me gifts I can respond with
another gif it works just like texting
this is not a lie it's not a stretch
this works I'll put the number in the
description as well but it's five one
three two eight six two one seven two
you can call - but voice mailing doesn't
work so you can't leave me a message
it'll just there's a pre-recorded
message of me telling you to text
in my way so the next thing that I
finally got active on my channel is the
sponsor button if you look down below
this video right next to the subscribe
button is a big blue sponsor button
click on that one it won't sponsor right
away it just takes you to the
informational page but click on that
button right now and you can see the
perks that you'll get if you sponsor not
only will you get a special markup
liar's heroes badge next to your name
anywhere that you comment on my channel
in the comments down there or in live
chat you'll get a special badge that
levels up with you the longer you've
been sponsored here's an infographic of
all the different tiers and timelines of
those badges and you'll get access to
custom emoji for live chats but in
addition to that those are very basic
stuff I wanted to offer even more perks
because at the end of the day sponsoring
my channel is helping me make projects
like who killed markiplier and a date
with markiplier I've talked about those
before those are big budget things who
killed markiplier costs a hundred
thousand dollars and was an absolute
financial loss but I didn't care I don't
care there was no way that ad revenue
was ever going to make up for the cost
of those videos and that was fine but he
just meant that I wasn't able to do them
all the time but if you guys sponsor me
I'm going to put that money directly
towards making more and more of those
projects and like I said earlier next
week is one of those projects we're
filming something I'll talk about that
later
I promise in this video I'll talk about
that later but I want to get through
this first but basically I wanted to
reward you guys more for helping me make
cool stuff like that and those videos
are not going to be sponsor only I want
to be very clear about that right off
the bat those are not sponsor only those
are for everybody to enjoy
but the sponsor perks that you do get is
once a month you will get a special
video it may be a short and stupid Mimi
video but you will get a special video
that only you will be able to find over
on the community tab all of these perks
are basically going to be on youtube.com
slash markiplier slash community if you
go to my main channel page and click on
the community thing you'll find it there
I'll put a link in the description but
also you'll get a special sponsors only
live stream where only sponsors will be
able to chat with me and again this is
not taking away from what everybody is
getting these are all supplementary to
what I'm normally doing it's not a video
that I'm robbed
from people who aren't sponsored and
only giving to sponsor people I'm making
another video I'm doing another special
livestream in addition to everything
else that I'm already gonna be doing and
sponsors will get access to a special
merch discount code that'll basically
offset the entire cost of the
sponsorship which is five dollars and
pretty much I'm gonna use the community
tab as a hub for all of my thoughts my
ramblings poles pictures
behind-the-scenes content stuff that
nobody's ever really seen before because
I wasn't comfortable sharing with it but
I might as well toss it on the community
tab all of that will be available for
you guys it's going to be a place where
I can talk to you in addition to texting
I'm going to be able to conversate with
you guys in an open manner get feedback
on what I'm doing get ideas for games
that I need to play all in the community
tab and I'm still working on this by the
way we need to get into YouTube's API
for this but I wanted longtime sponsors
to be able to access exclusive merch six
month I wanted people to be able to get
a special markup liar's heroes iron-on
patch for one year I wanted some special
shirt but for two years I wanted people
to be able to get a special markup
liar's heroes letterman jacket with a
rainbow heart right aloha and that's
just the beginning that's what I
definitely know I can provide on a
month-to-month basis I know I can do
that easily but I wanted to do more if
you guys are willing to sponsor my
channel I want to give you more than
what you're giving me I fall I always
want that to be the exchange if you're
giving me something if you're even
giving me your time I want to offer you
back so much more I want to always be
worth your time so please consider
sponsoring the channel it would mean the
world to me if you did and if you
sponsor right now there is already a
special video that is only available for
sponsors over on the community tab once
again that's youtube.com slash
markiplier slash community there's a
link in the description where you can
find a video where I explore whether or
not you can cook with cat food it's a
little bit of a weird concept and I made
it a while ago and I didn't know if I
was ever gonna post it but here I am
posting it so check that out right now
if you're already sponsored you can see
that right now but please consider
sponsoring it is only gonna help make
cool stuff for this channel now next I'm
finally talking about okay so I've been
working not only on this stuff but I've
been working on all these different
projects
so many different things are lined up
and coming to you guys that I'm just
super excited for the future but also
I'm very sorry
and I promise I won't ramble on too much
longer please like hear me out through
all this you heard me through all of
that and I'm so grateful but hear me out
through this I know
videos have been lacking and I know I
know that I've been not active on any
sort of social media and I understand
that but it's because I've been working
in the background and I've had so little
to show for it because it's so much
planning and none doing it but now
that's changed is next week we are
working on a worse - sketch that I'm
going to need you guys to help out on
for a special scene it's gonna be super
fun it's gonna be shot in about three
days and then hopefully it's gonna it's
only gonna take like two weeks added but
that's gonna come out next month and
I've been working on I've mentioned this
a few times but I've been working on
this huge like hundred and eighteen page
script for a huge project and I'm
finally ready to say that that is the
next choose your own adventure that I'm
going to be doing and it's it's bigger
than anything I've ever done before and
the reason it's so big is because I was
not able to fund it myself I needed
someone else so I pitched it to a
company and they haven't said yes yet
but I pitched it and they liked it I
mean that's months away that is months
away but I've been working oh my god
I've been working on that for so long
I've been there like thinking about that
non-stop it's just been this big old
wait on my life every spare moment of my
life is spent thinking about that
project in addition to all the stuff
that I've already been doing so I don't
have a lot of spare time anyway but I've
been working on that it's been pitched
the script is done it's gonna still need
some rewrites but it's done I love it
it's a choose-your-own-adventure it's
got like 64 videos planned anywhere
between 64 and 72 depending on like what
the budget we get but that is finally
gonna happen and it's us so cool it's
got four different new original
characters not any one you've ever seen
before it's got new original characters
of me it's just been like my baby for
the past few months and I haven't been
able to tell anybody about my baby and
I'm still not giving you a lot of
details about my baby until I get a
solid yes-or-no answer on it and I can
figure out a plan of how to make it
but like this is all part of it talking
with you guys as part of it like getting
all this underway as part of it getting
the sponsorship is part of it
getting the text messaging going is part
of it being able to communicate with you
guys is part of it you guys are part of
it you guys are part of this you guys
are part of everything I do and when I'm
not able to tell you about everything I
want to do I can't no I get so
frustrated that's why I sprout out all
I'm so excited I'm the Peter Molyneux of
of YouTube I just keep wanting to vomit
out all the details of everything I'm
working on but this year I made a
promise I made a resolution that this
year I was going to do more and say less
I was only going to tell people about
things when it was time to tell people
about things and now it's finally time
to tell me about things so just thank
you thank you for giving me a chance to
be myself thank you for giving me a
chance to push myself in ways I never
thought possible and I am more dedicated
than ever to making YouTube the place
where we make anything making anything
is possible absolutely anything is
possible here and if you sponsor thank
you if you text thank if you just enjoy
the videos that I'm gonna be making
thank you oh and before I leave one more
thing I'm working with YouTube to make
sure that if people sponsor one month
and then they can't sponsor the next
month they don't instantly lose their
progress on the badge what I want is for
people if you earned a badge you keep
that badge and if you sponsor again you
keep the progress that you've made in
the past because in my mind once a hero
always a hero you shouldn't lose the
progress that you've made on those hero
hearts if you can't sponsor for month to
month so I'll leave you with that thank
you everybody so much for watching
sponsor right now and check out the
community tab if you can and thanks for
watching
exciting stuff to come in the future I'm
so excited about it I came here I can't
even stop gushing about it I'd love you
guys know I love to gush oh god I love
to gush ahh this don't ask so much cool
stuff happening there's so much cool
stuff and I want to say so badly but I
want
until it's time well I'll give you some
hints in their community tab so thank
you everybody so much for watching I'm
so glad that you're part of this thank
you to everybody that's sponsored even
before it was ready and you didn't
expect any reward so I promise I'm gonna
shut up but that was the amazing thing
people sponsored and then I was like hey
you're gonna get perks and they're like
we didn't even expect perks why we're
just wanting to support you and I'm like
oh my god that's so nice but I'm gonna
give you stuff anyway it's like oh man
you guys are so awesome so special shout
out to everybody that has sponsored
already there's already a few people
with a green heart next to their name
down the comments but now I'm gonna go
I'm gonna leave it is I'm done now but
thank you everybody so much really truly
honestly thank you guys I am tickled to
death to see what the future brings so
I'll leave it now thanks again and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye